i want to take a quick break mid show to
bring you a pretty upsetting image and
no it's not cnn's court eunuch in his
skivvies it's even worse than that it's
john kerry
flying on an american airlines flight
without a mask
now first we thought it was fake because
carrie was flying commercial and because
of course he told us that
not wearing masks was immoral wearing a
mask was setting an example
you cannot have a president united
states setting an example
for people not having a mask and then
making it into a political issue
but he wasn't wearing a mask has he been
apprehended well as of right now john
kerry appears to be on the loose out
there but don't worry we've already
called the mask police as good
citizens no word on whether kerry was
dragged physically off
the plane but then he wasn't an elderly
woman in a bank of america franchise in
texas so probably not
if anything kerry's probably hoping
he'll get banned from flying commercials
he can get back on his private jet
and spew some carbon